um ricky bobby ten dollars freaking
bobby thank you bobby he says coco i can
retire you today
i'm gonna be submissive no
first of all i would never
i'm in a relationships of him even
asking that
but if you weren't like say you weren't
in a relationship say you are successful
say
um you take care of yourself and and you
do those things and you feel good about
yourself you found who you were um and
you have somebody who says hey like i
want to retire you you know like i don't
want you to work anymore i want you to
be my wife i will i work because i want
to work
and i i enjoy would you lessen your work
for
i would never do anything for another
person i used to do that when i was in
my 20s but do you think that
you you that would change if you found
somebody that
fit all those like categories for you in
that sense so would i stop building my
dream because i'm not like lesson maybe
you put more attention to maybe if i
have a kid i would put more attention
towards the kid and i would like i don't
know if when i get married how am i
going to feel maybe i'm going to want to
travel the world with my husband for a
year i don't know so like i can answer
that question then but i
i just don't want
that kind of relationship where
you have to give up who you are
to be
somebody's wife isn't that any
relationship like both parties have to
make sacrifices you make sacrifices you
might we make a compromise not sacrifice
in my opinion
i think sacrifices yeah say it again i
wholeheartedly think there's sacrifices
there's just some things that i can't do
as a wife and i'm okay with that like i
can't go into the after party with fresh
and fit by myself but that's okay that's
okay i think a lot of people have the
women have that fomo thing well what
happens if i compromise my life for my
man and it's just such an empty and
tired fearful narrative that i think
leads a lot of women astray
it's gonna be a dark time i think for
millennial and gen z women when they
realize they didn't invest their money
because most women aren't in your
position by the way like most women are
you know average income earners so they
didn't invest any money they didn't get
a relationship and maybe they have kids
like that's great but i mean having
children by your side on your deathbed
is not the same thing as like having
your husband there it's your kids can't
replace a man and i think earlier you
mentioned that you would lessen your
workload for a child but you said you
wouldn't listen your workload for a man
and so that would be why would he ask me
to lessen my workload like why would he
i'm actually curious like what yeah like
so let's say my my
yeah he what would he want me like not
to work so i can just do what no no i
can tell you i can tell you so
what i've witnessed from men who ever
asked their women to work less and i i
know a lot of established military men
with their wives and things like that is
because the woman has so much stress
from her job she's bringing it home and
it's making the entire household unhappy
so they're saying take time away from
that why don't you find something else
and that's not to say that you couldn't
start your own small business from home
i mean coco's not going to stay home and
like only make pancakes tonight but
she's going to do something she's not
that type of but that's normally what
i've seen why men say you need to quit
your job like the roi on this is
absolutely trash you're not even really
financially contributing i agree with
that but like i work for myself so that
i do what i want to do like if i want to
start a podcast i do it because i want
to do it i used to work for other people
and that also didn't work for me
but you could still overwork and it
eclipses your relationship and it
becomes a problem okay but that's that's
like a work life work life balance yeah
absolutely and that's what most of that
conversation is about is women have a
hard time juggling i want to say in the
west like women are expected to do all
these things and my message is well just
pick a couple of things you don't need
the whole thing you're expected to have
a libido stay physically fit well
attractive and then you have to cook
clean you have to raise kids and you
have to be that female role in a
relationship i think that's too much i
could do all of that you're gonna be
sleeping
but also like i grew up in the family
that like had everything like the one
percent family it comes with trade-offs
my dad worked 80 hours a week my whole
life i barely saw him yeah i didn't
really get to know him until i was older
you can't have everything something is
going to give so if you have a family
and you want to work that much it is
going to impact your relationship with
your children and your husband like you
you can't have everything
and you know now i'm okay with it
because i don't have college debt dad
i have a question for her what she said
before go ahead coco it comes to
sacrifices and you said uh i have to
sacrifice and i can't go for an after
party with fresh and fit
but for me when you're in a relationship
when you're like
into your man you don't want to go
yeah
so that was your that would not be a
sacrifice that would be your choice
so the thing about it is even though i
am married like i still fomo i'm 27
years old and you look at the dominant
narrative and it's like i should be i
should be getting drunk and ibiza with
my girlfriends so you get on instagram
you're looking around you're like oh man
like maybe i am missing out on something
but i i have to you know constantly
remind myself in my marriage that and
also my husband helps me with this too
i'm like like these people look happy
he's like no they're miserable i mean
they are miserable
do you i hear your point there by the
way because social media will basically
tell you don't be happy in your marriage
you're missing out you should be in visa
getting drunk with all your friends
right now you're like no
this is where i'm happiest yes do you
not go on trips with your girlfriends
because you're married
no no i wouldn't want to but i also you
wouldn't go on a girl's trip
no not unless it was with family or with
pearl
i mean i wouldn't there's no way it
would only be perfect
yeah but on
ali you wouldn't let's say your best
friend not pearl let's say that's me no
i'm just saying let's say you guys are
friends it's great but it's not your
only friend let's say another girl
in that red pill community that's all
you got you guys tortured there were
four of them okay let's say there are
some other friends i suspect you have
friends you have a bunch of family right
and she's like it's my bachelorette
party we're going to south beach
you wouldn't go no bachelorette party is
where women you know do the stuff the
stuff do what stuff they'd be hooking up
with dudes i don't know about all that i
was in a bachelorette two weeks ago
nobody hooked up with anybody
unfortunately honey i was there okay but
you're saying you don't want to put
yourself in a situation where you would
make a foolish decision or your husband
would be uncomfortable with the fact
that you might make a foolish decision
right and also i just don't want to
babysit women because you'll see women
do the most self-destructive things when
y'all are alone on these girl trips
you're like sarah like i have to go see
brad at thanksgiving like please knock
it off i just don't want to be
associated with that now that's not to
say that i wouldn't go to like you know
your pearl decides to get married and we
don't want to go and do a couple of
things but you're not going to find us
at the bar at 2 or 3 a.m it's just not
going to happen well i mean we are here
in in south florida in miami i see
bachelorette parties all the time i was
in austin i saw a bunch of bachelorette
parties they're everywhere
you're saying i mean look bachelorette
bachelorette parties people make some
crazy decisions you're saying you
wouldn't even put yourself in that
situation
go deeper why because of what you might
do what the girls are doing how your
husband would feel about it a little of
all the above explain it's just too much
of a liability it's really hard for me
personally to have female friendships
and i've just noticed that a lot of
women are self-centered right and so i
mean half the women at the bachelorette
party aren't even really happy for the
woman that's getting married in the
first place that's not true well i mean
i would beg to differ look at what
happened there's so many women that are
mad at me because i'm in a happy
marriage and that's not that's not even
just something that's happened online
with the viral tick tock but it's
something that i deal with in real life
but you know going to college uh being
on a college campus just hearing from
women who look down on me because
they're like well don't you want to do
more than that don't you want to be more
but no i'm okay with putting my
relationship before a bachelorette party
that's not a no-brainer coco would you
go to a bachelorette party if your
boyfriend didn't want you to go well
no no no he i was literally at a
bachelorette like two weeks ago in vegas
we were there for four days and i feel
like it all
like you have to know who your friends
are and what kind of people they are
like if if i have a random girl who just
like wants to party and her friends are
you know
i don't know girls for
i don't wanna i don't wanna insult like
i don't wanna name call but like if i
would not hang out with a group that i
find trashy and that could get me in a
situation that they would like go to
because i did like living in miami you
have people who constantly invite you to
parties to boats this that like you get
invited for
everything if you're a good-looking girl
and i make i made a conscious decision i
mean i'm making conscious decisions
every day where am i going where am i
not going so if i'm gonna i'm not gonna
hang out with a girl who like sleeps
with a different guy every week
just because that's not the person like
that's not my friends these girls this
bachelorette for example one is a banker
the other one is a top lawyer like
they're high-end
high-value women
who have their [ __ ] together some of
them are married some of them are not
maybe some of them have kids but like
that's the group i'm surrounded with i'm
not going to hang out with 18 year olds
who are gonna
you know so coco you you're
you're a classy girl real talk i'm
assuming i'm confident in saying that
the girls you hang out with
are classy ladies yeah no doubt but if
your boyfriend or serious partner
husband whatever was like listen
i love you babe but i don't want you to
go to vegas for this bachelorette party
i would say why he's like i just don't
feel comfortable i trust you mm-hmm but
i don't really like the concept of
bachelorette parties vegas penis straws
you know the whole yeah
what would you say
i
again that's not
what that's not that that's this is a
complete hypothetical i know but that
situation wouldn't happen to me because
like he's going to a bachelorette in two
weeks to i don't know where bachelor
sorry i don't know where he's going like
mexico or something but if he was
hanging out with some dudes that were
questionable and they were doing weird
stuff you'd be like honey i don't like
you point is you wouldn't make that
request he wouldn't make that request no
that's off the table i feel like if you
don't trust your partner like why are
you with them
nobody can make me cheat on my boyfriend
if i don't want to do it
and if somebody else is cheating on
their husband boyfriend that's not my
business
okay like what am i supposed to do by
the way i'm not no no i'm on team coco
here meaning like i've been on a million
bachelor parties if my girl wanted to go
but i do appreciate ali's perspective
saying look
i don't even want to put myself in that
position that's a unique perspective can
i just i'll go during the day like
during the day as long as the sun is up
why because the freaks come out at night
exactly exactly come out at night i got
a bedtime 9 p.m that's your bachelor
party bachelorette party window you got
me from noon to nine that's it we'll do
one it'll just be me and you because
it'll be the only two goals i have a
question so
um you said you don't wanna be in a
situation where there's gonna be what
like what what would be
what's not allowed i don't wanna be
associated with three or fours i don't
want one
um
scantily clad women
you said three or fours three oh fours
it's 304 i mean what does that mean oh
is that is that what like yeah why do
you think it upside down on the
calculator
like i i remember boobless that's what i
remember with the calculator but why
just shout out to everyone using a
calculator out there get your money
right well why do you
call your friends hosts if they go for a
bachelorette party so
because a lot of these women that they
go to these bachelorette parties they
get done up dressed up to the nines and
they won't do the same things for their
man that's at home their boyfriend or
something so it's i understand you're
talking about a specific class of women
and by the way like they're obviously
the exception to the rule i know
professional feminine women they totally
exist i get that but most women they use
a bachelorette party as a cover-up and
an excuse i don't agree with that
because you don't look at the woman that
you're hanging out with like they're not
your average woman go to downtown miami
like get what do you mean by that
because you mean they're more high
caliber women i would say that they're
miami 304s no no so she's talking about
women that are in a higher socioeconomic
status for one and also they probably
figured out that you know it is
beneficial to their job to keep up their
looks as well right so that is a
specific class of woman okay that's not
your that is not regular schmeduler
women if you go to a regular average
but do you think that your friends are
regular schmegeler schmeguler
by the way i'd like everybody at home
right now if you're watching this just
say three times
regular smegular it's fun to say regular
mega the regular rec it's a fun word to
say go ahead and do it yeah and while
you're at it subscribe to valuetainment
money subscribe to valuetainment we love
appreciate having you here you ain't
regular schmegler you got your mind
right as you were ali no i'm i'm just
saying
i do keep my female circles small but
that's because i have specific values
i'm very family oriented i don't want to
go to the bar and it's hard for me to
come across you and your girlfriends
might be able to pull that off but i
can't pearl you you have the same
problem being your age just trying to
get women to go bowling yeah because i
don't drink and so it's like every 25
year old i meet just wants to go to the
bars well that's yeah okay that's just a
different type of person like i also
have a lot of friends who are just like
you know i mean not friends like
acquaintances that are what who are just
into like chasing the party and they
regular regular they're looking for the
party yeah i mean i think regular girls
that's what they do especially at 25.
by the way there's nothing wrong with
that go ahead and part of this you know
if you're 38 and still being regular
schmeguler getting wasted that you
probably have a problem well i've just
found that you can get more done and
like i don't know my life got better
when i stopped drinking like a lot
better i hear you and i like i i would
recommend it to anyone my new year's
resolution this past year was less
drinking and less cursing
and i've been getting [ __ ] wasted i'm
just kidding right